quel monde après la crise planétaire du
comic 19
[Musique]
verra-t-on davantage d'attention portée
aux personnes âgées les liens
intergénérationnels ce sont 10 solucom
le regrettait ce responsable d'une
maison de retraite
il y a une vingtaine d'années déjà on
est dans une société où on jette les
vieilles choses on est société ou
symboliquement aux gets les vieilles
personnes
en réaction dès les années 70 de rares
initiatives se sont mises en place pour
recréer des liens entre jeunes et vieux
comme dans ce centre de vacances en
bretagne en 1978 ouvert à toutes les
générations avec pétanque spectacles de
rue kuhn musiciens sur la plage et
beaucoup d'espoir de la part de la
journaliste
des rencontres qui pourraient donc
dépasser le cadre de l'expérience
bretonne et se multiplier dans
différentes régions de france
il y aura d'autres expériences en dehors
des vacances parmi les principales
initiatives locales qui vont surgir
construire des maisons de retraite
proche des écoles pour créer un contact
comme ici à haulchin dans le nord en
1982 une résidence pour personnes âgées
volontairement construite au milieu du
village
après maintes discussions nous avons
choisi cet emplacement
parce que d'abord il est aux côtés des
écoles primaires il est à côté d'un
centre sportif et il se trouve également
au milieu du bourg
c'est à dire que les personnes âgées ne
sont pas isolés elle sort elle reste
dans le village des communes irons
encore plus loin en faisant
littéralement venir les écoliers dans
les maisons de retraite
ce fut le cas à tarnac en 1984 cette
révision très sage
on n'a rien à dire au contraire ça donne
ça met une petite animation de l'année
une expérience cité en exemple qui se
répétera un peu partout en france
au fil des ans quitte à bousculer on a
vu des papiers des mamies qui nous ont
dit mais on n'a pas le droit d'aller
vers les enfants n'a pas le droit de
toucher à leurs enfants
il a fallu que nous parents on aille
vers les personnes âgées pour leur dire
mais free halte garderie maternelle
cantine les tout petits se mêlent aux
plus âgés pour le plus grand plaisir des
uns depuis un an à la maison de retraite
la dei
les rampes d'accès pour fauteuil roulant
se sont transformés en circuit pour
petits bolides mais aussi des autres
cellules ambiance terrible
moi je regrette même de ne pas la voir
disons plutôt ça
[Musique]